digamos que queremos encontrar la
solución de la ecuación diferencial de
la derivada de jake con respecto a x que
es igual a x por ye pausa en el vídeo y
traten de encontrar una solución general
para esta ecuación diferencial
resolvamos estos juntos siempre que
tengamos una ecuación diferencial para
resolver lo primero que tenemos que
hacer es revisar si es separable si
podemos dejar todas las x de x en un
lado y todas las 10 leyes del otro lado
aquí parece que si podemos hacer eso
multiplicamos ambos lados por de x para
dejarla de x del lado derecho y podemos
dividir ambos lados
entre jeff para dejarla ya del lado
izquierdo multiplicamos ambos lados por
1 entre estos se cancela con esto esto
es igual a 1 entre el borde ya que es
igual a x x de x ahora integramos ambos
lados de esta ecuación diferencial cuál
es la anti derivada de 1 entre y con
respecto a ayer pueden reconocer que
esto es el logaritmo natural de g y cuál
es la anti derivada de x con respecto a
x
incrementamos el exponente por lo que
nos queda x al cuadrado y lo dividimos
entre el exponente incrementado entre 2
y como tenemos integrales indefinidas
tenemos que agregar una constante en
algún lado de la ecuación aquí ponemos
más c como podemos despejar y aquí si
esto es igual a esto otro y si elevamos
a esto entonces debe de ser igual a
elevado a lo que está en este otro lado
la razón por la que esto es útil es
porque a cualquier potencia a la que
tenga que elevar es para obtener ya que
para eso es el logaritmo natural de
james se va a simplificar como ya nos
queda que es igual a la x al cuadrado
entre 2 más
de hecho podemos reescribir esto usando
las propiedades de los exponentes como a
la x al cuadrado entre 2 por el al ac y
ésta se es una constante arbitraria lo
que nos da otra constante arbitraria no
es la misma
esta es mayúscula y esta otra era
muscular la podemos poner aquí enfrente
podemos decir que es igual hace por el
ala x al cuadrado entre dos y con esto
terminamos encontramos la solución en
general para esta ecuación diferencial
original una de las cosas divertidas de
las ecuaciones diferenciales es
verificar que nuestra solución satisfaga
la ecuación diferencial calculemos la
derivada de jake con respecto a x mi
prima es igual a aplicamos la regla de
la cadena la derivada de lo que está
adentro con respecto a x que es igual a
x2 x x entre 2 lo escribimos y luego
calculamos la derivada de lo que está
afuera con respecto a lo que está
adentro que es igual a c por el a la x
cuadrada entre 2 y pueden decirme que
esto luce diferente a lo que está aquí
pero recuerden que es igual a c por el
ala x cuadrada entre 2 esto es y es lo
mismo que esto de aquí que prima o la
derivada de con respecto a x es igual a
x porque y ya es igual a esta expresión
y con esto terminamos